I want to grind up and dance with me
just kind of like an inappropriate
sexual very close dance only if you're
engaged weird stuff happens before the
cameras turn on I'll tell you that so I
wanted to start tonight off with a true
story there's a guy who lives on my
street who obviously just got back from
a tropical vacation I say obviously
because when he left he was like a pale
pale white guy and like powder just
picture powder and when he came back he
was like really really tan like real
like three shades darker
I'm talking like Cadbury Creme Egg color
you know I mean like when I saw him I
got seasonally hungry so when I saw him
I said hello you know like people do and
he was like and that's true he kind of
sounds a little bit like Ray Romano's
and there was this pause like he just
stood there looking at me so dark just
staring right at me but I could tell in
that pause he was waiting for me to
address the tan you know I mean just
kind of but I was like no way I'm not
gonna play this game I'm just gonna
leave it alone and I'm gonna move on
with my day but before I could walk away
he stops and he goes hey wait a minute
Peter did you get some Sun it kind of
looks like you got some Sun he asked me
if I had gotten some Sun the man who had
all the Sun the man who looked like he
just got back from vacation on the Sun
he was fishing for a compliment and I
was like no no way I will not engage I
will not fall into your bronze
cocoa butter scented trap I just went
not really and just went on with my day
no dice but okay then I thought about it
why why did I do that he was just
fishing for a small shot of love just
Britt's just a sprinkle that's not a
word sprinkle and that's the great irony
I thought about the people sometimes who
want and need love are sometimes the
most difficult or annoying to give it to
but I say shine some love on them anyway
that's what love is all about spreading
that around anybody can love
lovable people people walking around
proud like oh I love Jerry Jerry of
course you love Jerry he's great he
remembers your birthday and gets here
that thing you only mentioned once in
passing three months ago as a gift that
Jerry
oh my god you got me the band Boba Fett
action figure that actually shoots the
back missile this is so rare and hurt so
many kids
thank you no you love Jerry Jerry's
awesome but loving Jerry isn't special
the real virtue is loving people that
aren't that lovable try loving Mariana
the lady who decorates her cubicle like
it's her apartment she needs love
she sure not getting it from her 20
plants and her ceramic frog knickknacks
and photos of other people's kids it's
not show her love I'm sure I feel some
of you being like I don't need to be
told I love Pete I love a lot of people
back off I got a lot of love in my life
I love tons of people I love my
girlfriend
yeah you should love your girlfriend she
blows you
that's easy but I'm saying when you lay
down at night and you turn off the
lights and take an inventory of your
soul he'll be glad you were kind to that
IT guy who only talks about wrestling
moves and wants to demonstrate them on
you like that's the only time he's happy
and you gave it to him he's like bro
it's like it's like I can't give me your
arm give me your off give me our it's
like this and then I pull my my fingers
like in your eyes like with that like
that okay he's having the time of his
life don't shun that guy because loving
perfect Jerry Jerry
with his unbreakable eye contact firm
handshakes hilarious anecdotes about
b-list celebrities walking around a
party like I tell you about the time I
saw Steven Seagal tackle a pickpocket
[Music]
loving him isn't admirable but I'll tell
you what would be next time I see my
neighbor I'm gonna go hey looking good
you Ray Romano sounding bastard you get
some Sun
[Music]